Evan gershkovic has spent six years in
Russia reporting on the news
now he is the news after the authorities
arrested him for spying
this the first time he's been seen
publicly since the end of March like an
exhibit in a glass cabinet within a
Moscow courtroom
his lawyers applied for bail while the
authorities assembled their case
but gershkovich knew his chances were
Slim
that is
gershkovich's arrest was trumpeted on
state television the host of this talk
show said he was trying to obtain
classified information about an arms
Factory the Enterprise a total failure
she says
but the Americans call his detention
totally illegal The Ambassador in the
blue jacket casting a disapproving eye
after his plea for bail was denied she
made her displeasure known
the charges against Evan are baseless
and we call on the Russian Federation to
immediately release him
such comments have infuriated the
Russians here the British Ambassador
exits the foreign Ministry after a
diplomatic dressing down she and her
American counterpart accused of
interfering in the legal process
criticism of President Putin's
Administration and invasion is unwelcome
here solitary protests against the war
in Ukraine are quashed by police and
reporters must be careful what they say
but some analysts think there's another
reason the American was arrested it's
the kremlin's intention to create a pool
of hostages in order to
in order to bargain with the United
States about some Russians who was
detained in different Western countries
disputes in prisoner swaps form part of
the conflict but the fighting continues
in occupied Ukraine and the Russian
leader made a rare visit speaking to
commanders in the region of her son and
luhansk
I'm here to listen to your opinion he
said somewhat unconvincingly his
spokesman told Sky News you now see the
leader visiting the regions more often
that may be essential as some Russians
question his leadership their
commander-in-chief unable to win the war
John Sparks Sky News